i would take bill clinton's democratic
party any day over the democratic party
of these current crop of of radicals
so right now during the dnc
there was the dnc lgbtq caucus meeting
and a member of this caucus jay mai
i don't know who that is described
what their aims are you know democrats
in recent days have said we're not about
abolishing the police we're not about
well j my in this open democratic caucus
meeting says that is
exactly what we are for we're talking
about abolishing the police we're
talking about abolishing ice we're
talking about abolishing prisons
there it is there it is and you remember
what aoc said when when
the democrats continued to hear the
younger crops say we're abolishing the
police we're abolishing ice we're
abolishing prisons
they said well abolishing the police
doesn't really mean abolishing the
police and then aoc came out with a
press statement god bless her i mean she
at least she was honest about it she
goes
no abolishing the police means
abolishing the police doesn't mean
removing a little bit of funding or
moving some funding around it means
actually abolishing getting rid of the
police
so that's the that's the democratic
party it's so funny what they've been
trying to do is hide some of these
sessions
but part of the the issue with them
pushing this continued lockdown
needlessly pushing this continued
lockdown
is these sessions are all on video and
it would seem that
we've got republican operatives in every
single one of them and so the video
keeps leaking and then what happens when
the video leaks
well the biden campaign has to distance
itself right because the biden campaign
is pretending
that this is a moderate democrat
campaign for a moderate democrat party
even though we all know that the minute
joe gets into office if he's even aware
that he gets into office you're going to
have this crop of radicals
running the country so the biden
campaign says i bet the police
the campaign has been very clear when it
comes to defunding the police they do
not support defunding the police and i
don't know how many times we have to say
this
on this network or others but that is
the case now at other times
the biden campaign has seemed very open
to defunding the police but neither here
nor there
they're denying it now i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
you